hey brennan hey theo this is dan in
tampa again
um just wanted to go over a video that i
saw about
an orangutan kind of groping on this
lady's frontal region
um i don't know if that's illegal if
that's legal
if that's abuse and any sexual assault
or something
i don't know how i felt about that but
what i want to know is how you feel
about it
king intersting it that molesting monkey
i mean look i want to say that this la
times writer is [ __ ]
a lot of these articles seem like they
don't really come from anywhere and
there doesn't seem to be a lot of proof
with any of this stuff
yeah so i haven't seen this guy like
i've never seen anything go down but
you know it just sounds like just kind
of typical
uh animalia behavior yeah i want to say
also
the this accusation of this orangutan is
21 years ago i wasn't there
you know what i'm saying i think your
boy's going down we have video footage
oh we got the actual video
oh i don't blame the orangutan though oh
damn
team better stay out of la tell you that
much
[Laughter]
a rang of bang bro i wish that dude
would freaking get loose in la man
i'd love to see the new york times write
an article about that about that
orangutan
he wouldn't give a [ __ ] bro [ __ ]
he'd come at me and there's too much
there's too many animal rights out here
for
him to get in trouble too they say they
he he had a pilot green lit on animal
planet and they canceled it
[Laughter]
dude that's crazy i'm about to say the
same joke for the first time in our
lives in 101 episodes
we've finally arrived at the same joke
dude i cannot believe that our dads
both are missing a [ __ ] same same
kingdom that said this yeah
bro the last hope we have as a species
is that animals strike back
and start showing people what's what
yeah the apes doug
even this screen shot he's like check
this out ring thing's aggressive
bro but dude rumor is also that the girl
had been sending messages to the
orangutang on ig
yes so it's tough call man
i'm with the orangutan though but here's
the girl it's hot though
let's just call it one there it is very
hot man and
i think if you are if we did evolve from
animals right like it says we did
but also people don't think that we did
and i'm not sure
but if it's if we did animals are going
to be pissed
when the animals look around the animal
kingdom they don't see any there's no
nice tits bro i've been to the zoo dude
you know what i'm saying every now and
then maybe you see something that's got
a nice [ __ ] little baby bag hanging
on yeah some of those gorillas are
banging though doug
some some of the asses on the baboons to
get you going you feel me
no keep going buddy
i want to see how this ends oh dude
check out the tits on this chimpanzee
though
okay i'll i'll agree not bad okay
not bad for some [ __ ] woods titties
but i'm talking about if you
bring those [ __ ] to south beach dog
you ain't getting in the clubs
that's right you ain't getting a
fountain blue with them saggy tits i'll
tell you that right now
yeah yeah you are bro with them [ __ ]
l cups with them hairy l cups
with them long elves oh dude
those things only look good by fire
light on freaking national geographic
television
so that's what i'm saying a monkey
probably they're so used to seeing these
trash bag titties around the zoo yeah
that's a good call
when they finally see a decent cup you
know a cultured cup
yes bro we can't you can't blame that
monkey for
finally finally first time see that
monkey's probably taking a thousand
pictures and finally he's reaching for a
good cup yup
i'm with the orangut thing
is the king in this game